what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we have a little bit
more insight today on why Marvel Studios
is not attending San Diego Comic-Con of
this year they are not doing their Hall
age panel if you have not heard however
we'll talk in this video how I believe
that they might be planning their own
special event and in this event they
should be giving us the details that
they were going to give us at San Diego
Comic-Con however it sounds like Marvel
Studios might not have all of the
details locked down themselves for what
they are trying to do right now and
there are many things that affect what
they are doing right now in their
planning process and we'll break that
down but right now as it stands it looks
like Marvel Studios is going to do
another update for their Phase 5 and
Phase 6 schedule relatively soon so we
could be looking at even more changes
this could be both good and bad but
we'll talk about what Marvel Studios has
planned as far as their slate
announcements are concerned in the
upcoming near future and if you want to
stay up to date on the MCU be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos we're also doing a
giveaway if you subscribe and comment
you're entered for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or DC items the winner gets to
pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month only a few days
left now although Marvel Studios is not
attending San Diego comic-con's Hall h
this year you should know that they have
been attending other cons and Kevin
feige has recently been attending events
and they have actually shown footage for
some Phase 5 and 6 projects like
Deadpool 3 and Captain America Brave New
World so they are still actively
promoting upcoming projects even if they
don't know the exact release dates when
these projects are actually going to be
coming out both for movies and Disney
Plus shows and that's the first thing we
need to talk about before we dive into
the possible Marvel event that they
might have and this could be pretty much
the main reason they are deciding to
skip San Diego Comic-Con this year there
are many reasons like the SAG strike the
writer strike but what it really comes
down to is they don't exactly have the
full plan for Phase 5 and phase six yet
and this is also caused by multiple
factors one could be Jonathan Majors
this is kind of a big one Marvel Studios
is waiting for the outcome of the
Jonathan Majors trial where he was
accused of allegedly assaulting his
ex-girlfriend now if you haven't caught
the latest video I did updating you on
everything that his team has presented
to the court they have presented a lot
of evidence that does point to him being
innocent and this does include a lot of
footage and it does include a lot of
eyewitnesses that are willing to testify
on Jonathan Major's behalf but
regardless it does put Marvel Studios in
a very sticky situation but hopefully
what Marvel Studios and Disney are doing
right now is waiting for the actual
court trial to finish and hopefully
they're waiting to make their decision
until then that way if he is found
innocent he will continue on as king the
Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe however if the opposite is true
if he is found guilty they will more
than likely replace him and since the
next Avengers movie the King Dynasty is
clearly all about Kang and since
Avengers Secret Wars is all about King
as well Kang is most likely going to
show up in random projects throughout
Phase 5 and phase six so that makes it
kind of hard for Marvel to proceed right
now with certain projects where Kang is
supposed to show up since they can't
really have Jonathan Majors play came
currently until the trial is determined
this is going to be a pretty big hang up
for Marvel Studios right now this pretty
much makes it to where some projects
they actually can't proceed with fully
that is because obviously King will only
be in a few scenes here and there but
still while Marvel Studios waits for
that it does kind of give them a little
bit of a delay for those certain
projects now the second reason we know
that they have delayed things in the
past and might possibly delay some more
things in the future is because they are
trying to make the projects better
better in quality we have talked about
this a lot in the channel Disney's CEO
Bob Iger and Marvel Studios president
Kevin feige have both commented that
they are going to be focusing more on
quality and less quantity for Disney
Plus shows and Kevin feige has specified
that this probably means both of these
things one producing less Disney Plus
shows and two spacing them further apart
so instead of having five to six Disney
plus projects with special presentations
and series a year they are probably only
going to have between three or four and
they're going to be spaced out and
probably instead of having four movies a
year they're going to have three now
this means we will have less content per
year but if it makes the content better
then it's a win for us Marvel fans and
at the same time a lot of people have
complained that the quality really
hasn't been there for Marvel Studios
lately so this should be a win-win and
then of course we have the rider strikes
and the SAG strikes this of course does
affect Marvel Studios if the writers
can't write and actors can't act or
promote their movies pre-production and
production for movies and shows does get
put on hold and according to Insider
Alex B from the cosmic circus Marvel
Studios is planning on doing another
slate update relatively soon so
hopefully we won't be in the unknown for
that much longer now as far as how
they'll do their slate update and since
they are missing San Diego comic-con's
Hall h which is always the biggest
Marvel event of the year I'm hoping that
they take it into their own hands once
they have some things figured out and do
their own little special event this will
be virtual and this will be very similar
to what they did back in 2020 when San
Diego Comic-Con was canceled now they
originally did this big event for Disney
in general and they did this at Disney's
investor day but Marvel Studios had a
whole 20 minute panel where Kevin feige
came out himself and himself only and
talked about the future of phase four
and a little bit about phase five as
well and they did a ton of reveals Kevin
feige did announcements like announcing
that Jonathan Majors was going to be
playing Kang and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania they also announced cast
members for Loki One Division the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier and many of the
other projects as well they also
announced the director for the Fantastic
Four which was always pretty much going
to be coming out in phase six now the
director has changed recently but the
fact is this event that happened in 2020
way before phase five or phase six was
talking about Phase 5 and phase six so
if we do have another event that is
going to be like this Marvel Studios can
talk about Phase 5 and Basics and
basically give us a road map of where
they want to go and an update on where
they are right now the only problem is
Marvel Studios has to kind of figure
that out first yesterday again Insider
Alex P from the cosmic circus tweeted
this out there isn't even a concrete
path to phase six let alone a two-part
Secret Wars basically stating the path
to phase six is not concrete yet and
we've heard the rumors that Marvel
Studios is considering making secret
Wars into a two-part event well that
isn't concrete yet Marvel Studios is
still determining what they are going to
do and again we've talked about why they
haven't exactly decided yet I think King
is a pretty big part he is obviously the
main villain of the entire Saga so
literally they are just waiting to see
what happens with the trial of Jonathan
Majors now this begins in August and
whenever it's done I believe that
they're going to figure out what they're
doing get their road map complete and
then tell us the fans because they know
we're waiting they know we're
disappointed that they are skipping San
Diego Comic-Con and they know we want an
update and good old Kevin feige likes to
deliver to the fans and since Alex B is
stating that we are going to be getting
a slate update I'm hoping since they
missed San Diego Comic-Con they will do
some type of a fan event now Disney's
investors day has already passed this
year so Marvel Studios could take it
upon themselves to do something like DC
has done over the years DC has done DC
fandom and I'm hoping that Marvel
Studios will kind of take a play from DC
and give us our own special Marvel
Studios event one where they have their
own virtual panel and Kevin feige comes
out and talks about the upcoming
projects talks about the upcoming cast
members for the projects and gives us an
update on what exactly to expect as far
as the schedule is concerned and what
projects are going to be coming out and
which actors are going to be playing
which roles now Marvel Studios did
recently give us an update on the
release dates for movies and shows and
this was through variety they just used
an outlet to do this however I don't
believe they'll do this in the future
simply because they are skipping San
Diego Comic-Con and they're not the only
Studio doing this we just heard that
Sony is going to be skipping out as well
so unfortunately no Spider-Man 4 updates
of any kind at San Diego Comic-Con but
fingers crossed Marvel Studios does do
some type of event they have done it in
the past so it is definitely in their
wheelhouse to do it plus not to mention
the fans are what Drive everything and
Kevin feige knows this and Kevin fagi
does think of the fans a lot so fingers
crossed we do get some type of event in
the near future but let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below and if Marvel
Studios decides to do another one of
these events that they did a few years
ago what would you like out of it let us
know down below you can also check us
out on patreon now we do have a website
and we do have a Discord server we'll
link all of those in the comments down
below and of course don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
me